[Music]
yeah thank you for having me on your
show
CJ yeah maybe welcome but you're a giant
pain in the butt to Tommy Robinson the
former founder of the ADL now I wanted
to talk about all your good stuff I love
the way that you you banter him and
troll him for for it to use an intern
Internet parlance but make tell it to my
audience a little bit about who Holly is
first okay welcome be honest me I'm a
weaver to Islam it's been about five
years since I came to Islam I've
researched a religion for about good
quit three four years before I accepted
it and so I'm from Kurdish back when I'm
kurdish from Turkey my family are not
Muslim and I got involved into the
taoist endow is basically you know
telling people about Islam what I found
really is about instead of what people
think it is so basically yeah that's
that's that's what it is I'm 28 years
old
yeah London Northeast only North is cool
and so so were you a a non-believer
before you reverted back to Islam or did
you start off as a as a Muslim and then
left the faith and come back to it well
to be honest well in this time we
believe input is born a Muslim and then
their parents change them to ever face
they belong to but the question that
you're asking is not that so basically
no I only believed in God I never had no
religion before I didn't believe in
Islam I didn't believe in anything I
don't have a religion I just believed in
like a high intelligence right well yeah
one of the things I like about you on
Twitter is is you're very competitive
against these Islamophobes but you know
you do it in a polite way in a very
reasonable and rational way and you try
and point out that you know that the
floors and the folly in in some of the
technical kind of stereotypes and tropes
that guys like Tommy Robertson try to to
disseminate about Muslims so how did you
behave you know tell me how it began
with you and Tommy I know that he
accused you of being involved the
Manchester bombing is that right yeah
yeah that's to be honest I would say
that's where it began but to be honest
he's been somebody who
I've been keen to have a dialogue when
to be honest you know III don't have any
classy videos where sir and Muslims go
and try to be physical with him I don't
agree to this behavior you know it's not
the right thing to do to be honest
because you know it just shows our
weakness you know in a way a psychic
can't answer his arguments and we're
restoring resorting to violence and
that's contrary to what I want to do I
just want a discussion man this is what
I want to do I like talking I like I
mean all kinds of people I I have I know
people that Jewish Christian atheist all
kinds of backgrounds yes we did form but
we have a dialogue so to be honest I've
been seeing his videos that it does and
he picks on these people that don't know
much and it annoys me because I'm not
look you're picking on somebody maybe
the guy doesn't know as well as much you
know and you're making it seem like you
know what you're talking about not only
that your hate preaching but on Twitter
it all started I think last year good
the era go I think where he the
Manchester bombings happened and it was
it was a tragedy you know it's like any
charge that happens around the world
you've got people in Iraq by being blown
up into pieces
millions you've got people in Burma
people all over the world you can see be
Muslim or not so these things are
happening right sadly because some
people are after money or you and then
you've got other people who are hate
preaching support extra money in their
pocket like Tommy Robinson said he's
made 60,000 pounds of his book so you
can see he's there to make money on this
now I think it's nice not only the fact
that I think he's also I think he has
something personal with his time I think
where he grew up maybe he got bullied by
Muslims or whatever it may be and now
he's expressing that hatred by attacking
the religion itself so therefore he made
the tweet saying that jihadi a leave me
you had a lead on me that I did a video
asking Muslims brothers and sisters to
not go to the Drake concert because it's
a place where in our religion it's not
permissible to be in such a place where
there's alcohol music and he twisted
that and insinuated that I had prior
knowledge therefore I was asking Muslims
to not attend it because they might get
hurt this is what he was insinuating so
when he did that that's where it all
began so I was like okay hold on a
second I'm gonna get the police involved
because now you put my life in danger
you claim that I'm a jihadi who has
prior knowledge to his attacks you've
actually put my life in danger a danger
and irony is that
yesterday he was the god the guy who ran
over Muslims in Finsbury Park mosque in
court he claimed that he had direct
messages from Tommy Robinson and Britain
first and he was basically kind of
radicalized even if I'm not mistaken
they did say that he had some statements
written the words like Tommy Robinson
uttered letter left in the van so you
can see that here that he is actually
the true story that's happened he's
radicalized somebody he's been involved
partially at an event that's happened at
air event but now if you what he did
with me was a lie an absolute full story
that I had prior knowledge to Manchester
bombings I found out disgusting so my
journey of exposing this guy really
slide them because it is showed that
this guy's careless he doesn't care he
just asked his nonsense just so his
followers can clap and say yay hooray
Tommy now he does works I'm not gonna
come and deny it because you see Allah
says to us in the Quran speak the truth
even if it's against yourself he does
stuff about grooming gangs and terrorism
etc that's ok I can say you know what
you're doing something there I'm not
gonna say what you're doing there is bad
the problem is why is it only why are
you it's Asian men that you're after
ok no problem we should hate grooming
gangs be they're white or not
I mean Muslim or non-muslim we should
hate terrorists be they Muslim or not
Muslim I find it very sickening that the
approach is taking is like no I only
hate the Muslims that do it when I'm
like look we should hate the act whoever
is thought by so he has that approach
and I just believe he's a hate preacher
and because of him and his life life
Britain first and Isis and other
extremist groups they are old on one
side you know I don't know if you can
see on the screen here you can see the
screen there's a there's a thin white
line here that departs the you know it's
me and then there's there's another
screen yet
see as the the left hand side I don't
know initially maybe I'm on the left
hand side yeah example there's a thin
line you've got these three must be its
brain first I says Tommy Robinson these
hate preachers put them all onto one
side
you have the British public we are all
on the other side we Muslim or
non-muslim yet now they are preaching
hate and British public
for example the those terrorist attacks
are happening in London they are
suffering
why because Isis and their lights are
preaching hate that Hampton Chowdhury
I'm sure I believe isn't he preacher is
preaching hate and we've got emotional
young Muslim men who are seeing when
this guys come in and saying look
they're blowing our brothers and sisters
up in Iraq they're blowing doing this
they're doing that now this emotional
person is thinking okay how what can I
do to combat this I know I'm emotional I
can't express myself with my words
I only know violence I'm gonna express
that by doing the same thing they do to
us
and I'm saying hold on a second our
religion doesn't teach that you're a
hate preacher and because of you you're
not carrying the act out but your silly
followers are going out of it and doing
that now the same thing is happening
with John Robinson Britain first these
guys are preaching eight and who is
doing the dirty work young young and old
men like that guy
mr. Osbourne where there are none what I
think and the likes are doing the same
thinking you know what look at these
people who are running and our people
over blowing up our kids we need to do
something and then when they seem pretty
chummy Robinson on the video saying you
know we need to take action we need to
tackle this look a stomach problem when
you've got people are key to Hopkins
saying we need we need a final solution
to this Muslim problem what do you think
is gonna happen when a young white man
is watching us and thinking yes these
people are doing this this we how are
they expressing their feelings they
expressing it by violence some of them
you know and this is why I say they're
on one side and the British probably you
know non Muslim or Muslim on one side
and we are getting the the bad things
that happened to us you know well gate
was suffering whether ones will go out
thinking okay who's gonna kill me who's
an attorney and they they're just
pocketing in money and cashing in and
they agenda whatever it may be
we're doing the song yeah I mean they're
people like what groups have Britain
first and Haiti and an individual spot
Tommy
use the same kind of propaganda
framework as groups like Isis they they
portray any group that's under threat
from an out group and then by separating
the two entities they're encouraging and
inciting violence against the out group
I mean we saw Tommy Robinson is you know
well you retweeted one of my tweets a
video Tommy Robinson giving a subtle
wink to people at Darren Osborne too too
young
a do thugs on the street to say we need
to clean out the Islamic problem yes I
mean when when you when you're a 22 year
old and you're drunk in a pub and you
you see an Islamist you know use that
inverted commas a terrorist attack in
London I think you hear somebody like
Tom and Robinson you think she's I gotta
take matters into my own hands
and that's what Salafi jihadis similarly
do who subscribe to the ISIS ideology
yeah
did you see that did you see what you
had is I said Salafi jihadi so and I use
that term loosely oh you know because
you know guys groups like Isis on
Salafis they think they are and Salafis
don't encourage violence but yeah I
would say the Creed of Salafism is
basically it's actually totally against
this like these people are called
actually the whole Hawara Joe I don't
have authority across so basically why I
was saying was Hawaii if you heard my
discussion with Tony Robinson and
basically you could see there the eye I
said Jim do you know about how erotic
and he was like who's that no I don't I
don't know and the college are searching
group I do they have an ideology and
this is this side at the time of the
Prophet peace be upon him you know
they're an extremist group these this
group is there to cause like violence
from day one if you look at who to the
four rightly guided
Holly Holly furs like for example
American cotton no Abu Bakr
Wolfman and Ali and they even attended
the qumari these people they are enemies
of Islam you can see they are our
enemies greater enemies right because
they look like us and they took like us
you know and maybe they look like us
therefore they are a greater enemy to us
you get Mackenzie yeah
this is who they are and these are the
people who are Isis you know they are
known for their trees there are certain
traits about them where you know then
they will take people at the fold of
Islam they will come to me and be like
you are just you know with you still you
know you you you you know your lack and
no root Muslim jun-chan see me any means
stop Jim Channon see so this is what to
meet their needs even know how hard it
is and I was really sure which is
incredible this is a guy that's written
a book on Islam and he still that he
doesn't know a basic term in Islamic
cultures I believe it's his friend's
book I when I talked to him I said your
friend's book because I will eat my
socks
if this guy's words in that book I'm
ready to my socks if this guy's rich in
the book that's why he's avoiding me
because he knows he has two problems
here
140 character tweet all he's done is
copy and paste the whole Quran and then
added these commentaries off he's got
this weird if you read the Koran
Baptists run and where'd you get this
from
you know and he's in big trouble because
I'm gonna ask him a question did you
read did you write the book if you did
you have to answer my questions if you
didn't you've been lying but it's your
book mhm yeah yeah no Joe so how much to
have you received for it I mean his
followers are quite rabid and you know
so what have you received any sort of
threatening noises from his followers
no it's like you know you're they're
calling me names I'm gonna do this when
I see you this that tell me where you
live you know all these kind of answers
you know and what about dressing your
daily day-to-day life you know offline
when you know in in the streets of North
East London you notice that the
hostility towards Muslims has you know
have you felt the increase in in the
last 12 months allows 24 months stories
even if it's not myself I can hear these
stories that are taking place you know
and not definitely mine you know there
is a hostility
increasing and you see that's the reason
why I'm so passionate about what I do
because the thing is we need to
education is
you know it's very key you know to
educate oneself because if you don't
what happens is this is what happens you
know you're just gonna get people
thinking okay what can we resort to
violence so therefore we need to educate
the people say hold on a second mate
you're being taken for a big ride you
know you're being actually taken
advantage of it's the same with the
Muslims but I'm not just saying it's
just Tony Robinson look I'm telling you
if I knew where these Islamic hate
preachers are yeah like it's hot if I
could if I knew where they are I would
personally go and question them the way
I do with Tony Robinson almost up above
Lima and young Charlie these people
rocked up you know and that's what now
what I see is it's just tackling and
combating because to educate people to
say look this is what it's not really
teachers and you're not gonna agree with
everything I'm not gonna remove your way
of life but you need to understand that
we are not here to be like yes we have
to take over the country and we want all
the non Muslims dead well like where'd
you get this one these are the fairy
tales yeah absolutely I mean see crap I
mean I speak to obviously we've produced
podcasts from my journalism you don't
close to a lot of Muslim organizations I
speak to Muslims on a daily basis and
every single Muslim I know will you know
strongly distance themselves from any of
the rubbish ramblings that sort of like
anime Ari will say so therefore I can I
can't understand why Islamophobes don't
see that Muslims are on the same side as
them and being against extremism but
unfortunately the media and groups like
ADL and people at Tommy Robinson they
portray an individual like anime Audrey
to be emblematic of Muslims writ large
yeah and ignore the voices of someone
like you well that's the thing you see
what it is is they both feed off each
other so it's supposed a narrative yeah
so Andrew do you know people like that
might look at Tony Robinson professor
man look see look at this these
disbelievers look what they're doing
look what they want and then you'll have
friends first and tell Roman be looking
and and charging me that look see look
what they do and so they both feed off
each other you know it's just
they both Anna cooking good like I
genuinely believe I genuinely believe
this year but Tommy Robinson and brain
first on their lights
I believe that when they hear of a
terrorist attack they are actually this
is disgusting I generally believe this
bi I believe they are like yes like they
like yes this is exactly it's gonna help
our course and I think this is sickening
you know the fact that they are cashing
in on this and the same with these
Islamic extremists they probably when
they see Iraq and Muslims being attacked
left right handed like good this helps a
narrative you know say someone like
Darren Osborne drive his van into
Finsbury Park mosque they're celebrating
it because it reinforces the narrative
they're white people that Muslims aren't
welcome in the West exactly go and then
that's why these young Muslims for
example some of them make it radical
they thinking yeah you know they see
these emotional things and it's
chuckling pictures look what's happenin
to our brothers but I see this I get
upset when I see like me kids in
Manchester being you know grown up into
pieces be in Iraq whatever it's it it's
it's shot no sickening but then again
it's just like you know these people
just using that to their advantage is
even more sickening do you think are you
optimistic or hopeful that one day
you'll accept your request to debating
well to be honest like I putting that
physically I don't he doesn't have a
thing of that with me it's just like I
don't give him a thing of okay please
accept it no I'm gonna find Tommy
Robinson one way or another I'm just
saying you know just make it my life
it'll be easier that's what I'm saying
to be honest you know I'm just gonna
it's gonna happen it's not even like
okay meet me please it's not that it's
just that okay I'm gonna find you
eventually and I'm gonna ask you this
I'm gonna ask you just save yourself
embarrassment at least they for your
ferocity you know what he was man enough
to have a discussion which he's not so
it's a lose-lose situation to me to me
it's a win-win situation when he says no
I'm not you're a liar you're a coward
and eventually when I find you I'm gonna
listen otherone situation for me what I
mean there's two schools of logic
there's the one one part of that would
say that what you're doing is fantastic
you're you're trying to debunk his
narratives
he's Islamic farming trucks
and then there might be another group of
people and say come on Ali what you're
doing is you're just elevating him by
giving him attention what would you say
to people who fall into that latter
group yeah it's really like let me talk
about this Tony Robinson is someone
who's been invited to many you know
media channels you know and to be honest
and the thing is he's not invited like
it's some special guest it is invited
just too so show what kind of summer for
what kind of big it is so the thing is
he's already out there yeah so it's not
like something small where you can say
you know okay you're given enough to
know the guy is out there is
brainwashing people you know you can see
you can see we've disguised Erin
Osbourne you know this this is the
byproduct of Tommy Robinson you know and
Britain first so you can see the danger
is causing so to be honest it's like you
know we can't just turn a blind eye to
it you know we can't just say okay just
we'll put it under the carpet and wait
for a distinct no we have to deal with a
head-on I believe we have to do with the
head-on and we have to challenge these
people and tell them that they can't
just carry on either and it's the same
with these extremists like Islamic
extremists yeah we have to do the same
with them you know we just put it brush
under the carpet
it's not gonna solve the problem we have
to do with it as Muslims and Muslims you
know we have to deal with these
situations and fix it you know otherwise
you know just gonna carry on no these
people just gonna you know people gonna
be huh agree and I think you're doing in
a very rational and reasonable manner
and so I'm one of those people falls
into the form of cancer I think that
you're doing you a good service and only
way quick and my listeners find you if
they wonder well find out more about you
well if you just have a lead out on
YouTube or Facebook Instagram snapchat
whatever you know to be honest yeah I
think you can just follow me find
finally yeah me and you I'm on YouTube
great might really appreciate your time
Ali what can my photos find your words
yeah once I publish the the the episode
I'll sing you the link and I'll see the
podcast details there okay not one thank
you was a lonely conversation right yep
thanks I look forward to talk thank you
for tuning in
hey give me one thanks honey
subscribe